Knight County isn't giving up on the
fight to hand count ballots eight news
now the only local TV station to get a
firsthand look at the process which was
then shut down investigative Vanessa
Murphy is here with the latest Vanessa
Kirsten night County Clerk Mark comp
telling me the new proposal is to hand
count ballots in silence a volunteer
would have a ballot and tally vote and
then a ballot control team would verify
results a main reason the hand count was
shut down is because observers could
hear some results since they were read
out loud now comp says the county
submitted the proposal this morning to
the Secretary of State for approval how
did we get here in March County
Commissioners asked the clerk then to
implement paper ballots that clerk
resigned comp who had previously said
Trump won the 2020 election took over
the hand count began last Wednesday in
groups of five volunteers one reading
votes from a ballot another verifying
that and three tallying results the ACLU
filed an emergency motion arguing
observers could hear results the Nevada
Supreme Court said the process violated
orders prohibiting the early release
piece of results prompting the Secretary
of State to send a letter stating the
hand count must stop comp points out
that machines are the primary method of
determining the results but he insists
the hand count is what most people in
Nye County want and this is in part
Kirsten because of false claims that
voter fraud is widespread by the way I
asked Mark comp for a copy of the
proposal and he said he was not inclined
to send it my oh my Vanessa what's the
next step of this process so I reached
out to the Secretary of State's office
and we're waiting for a response to
confirm the office has received the
proposal and to see if a decision has
been made about it back to you